a juror in the derek chauvin trial turns
out to have been a black lives matter a
protester
president biden oversees the rise of
racial polarization and crime
and ron desantis destroys biden's
anti-scientific vaccine approach i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first quick reminder there
are just two certain things in life
death and taxes benjamin franklin said
that but now
we also have to add that there's a third
certain thing and that is if you are
using verizon 18 t or t mobile you are
paying way too much
for your cell phone coverage and
switching to pure talk will save you
money in fact
puretalk saves the average family of
four over 800 a year here's the best
part you don't have to sacrifice
coverage because it's on the exact same
network as one of those providers
switching is super simple you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest
iphones and androids right now you can
get unlimited talk text and six gigs of
data
for just 30 bucks a month that's a great
deal unlimited talk tax six gigs of data
and you're saying yourself what what if
i go over what if i use more than six
gigs of data glad you asked if you go
over on data they're not going to charge
you for it that's just one of the many
reasons they have been named the top
wireless provider
by consumer affairs that other phone
company is going to try and confuse you
with what you get
not so with pure talk usa get started
today from your cell phone
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro you'll
save 50
off your very first month that's pound
two five zero say my name
ben shapiro and you say fifty percent on
your very first month from pure talk
usa save yourself a bunch of money by
switching your cell phone coverage
alrighty so
the biden administration came into power
promising moderation
a return to normalcy and instead they
are overseeing what looks
very much like the country coming apart
at the seams and the people who are
paying the price for that
are largely living in blue areas that
are being cleaned out
and there is a reason that the census
data shows that people are moving from
blue areas to red areas and it's because
blue areas increasingly suck
i mean it just is the reality of life
crime has gone up tremendously in places
like l.a where i used to live or new
york where a lot of my friends used to
live or places like chicago
where i have friends who are now moving
you know the fact of the matter is that
as
democratic policies start to have their
effect things
go bad which is why daily wire is now
reporting that chicago may be headed for
a violent summer over the weekend dozens
of people were shot seven were killed in
gun violence that spanned the city
a continuation of a trend that has
dogged chicago the nation's third
largest city
since last summer fox news reports more
than 45 people were shot
including a 14 year old boy seven were
killed in chicago city wide over the
weekend
according to the chicago pd there were
36 shootings reported from 6 pm friday
to 11 59 pm sunday
at least two others were stabbed
including one victim who succumbed to
his injuries
information released by the authorities
indicates the slain victims ranged from
to 37 the youngest victim died while he
was shot while driving on sunday he
crashed his car after sustaining
a bullet wound the youngest victim who
survived was just 14
years old so all of this of course is
terrible news but
it is mirrored by the fact that there is
terrible news in pretty much every major
american city when it comes to homicide
according to the washington post today
district officials in washington
launched their annual summer crime
prevention initiative it's fun that it's
annual right
i mean it's just like july 4th or like
summer camp
it's a summer initiative to stop people
from murdering each other in washington
dc it's annual it's an annual summer
crime prevention initiative
which sounds like the state fair against
a backdrop of a soaring homicide rate
and on the heels of a particularly
bloody weekend in the city now i i don't
know why this would happen
i mean they painted black lives matter
in giant yellow letters on the street
for god's sake they
renamed a square black lives matter
square in washington dc
i thought for the life of me this would
mean more black people would live
but as it turns out when you rip on the
cops and when you suggest the cops are
the problem
it turns out that more black people die
because more people die generally
and if disproportionately black people
die in homicides then more black people
will die in homicides
mayor muriel bowser democrat announced
the program at a news conference monday
at rosedale recreation center a
10-minute drive
from where a stray bullet struck a
seven-year-old through her pink t-shirt
two days earlier now you haven't heard
of that seven-year-old have you
you know her name we still don't know
the name of the 14 year old kid in
chicago because they don't matter to the
left they don't matter
that's not the narrative this is the
thing the biden administration
the left that is predominant in
america's major cities they have a
narrative the narrative is the great
threat to black americans
is the cops and that is a lie and it
means more black people will die
over the past weekend alone at least 11
people were shot and another person was
stabbed
three of those victims died bringing the
number of homicides in the district to
66 this year
a 38 increase from the same time in 2020
and it should be known that every year
in the united states about 20 black
people are shot unarmed by the cops
in the district of columbia alone 66
people have been murdered
this year acting dc police chief robert
j conte said as we prepared to kick off
the summer crime prevention initiative
i do i love it i mean again that it's an
annual thing is kind of hysterical
it is certainly not lost on me the
violent crime that we experienced in our
city this past weekend
these things are the reason why we do
the summer crime initiative it's the
reason why we are so committed to this
and we have been for so many years now
well
maybe if you keep doing the same thing
and it's failing maybe you should
probably change how you do that thing
a 20 year old man from northeast
washington delano harris was fatally
shot sunday evening in the edgewood
neighborhood
half an hour later police said louise
chiefs a 46 year old from southeast
washington was fatally stabbed near
boone elementary school in southeast
paul tyrone dorne whose age was not
immediately available died of a gunshot
wound to his chest on sunday night
a police report says he was shot in
self-defense seven-year-old reagan
grimes a second grader visiting from
maryland is expected to recover
after a bullet went through her chest
outside of the paradise at parkside
apartment complex on saturday
her family said they were visiting
relatives and she had gone outside to
play
well my favorite thing here is that
according to dc the big issue here is
that it's hot outside
you know as it gets hotter this is one
of the great
kind of statistical lies that they'll
tell you well you know when it's hotter
people murder each other more no
it's just the kids are out of school for
the summer and young people
disproportionately commit crime so that
that is usually why you have
a spike in the summer in terms of the
murder rate but the reason that you have
a spike this year over other years is of
course
because when you rip the cops when you
make it impossible for them to do their
jobs
then you're going to get a rising crime
and what we've seen is that there are
cultural
impacts to saying that cops across the
land are systemically racist
there are cultural impacts to saying to
citizens across the united states that
the police
are the enemy in fact it makes a
difference when you say this sort of
stuff it makes a difference in citizen
behavior
it makes a difference in police behavior
because people are not automatons
when you say that the cops are all
racist and that and
you're going to drag them into court
even if the body cam footage shows that
they did the right thing right or you're
going to drag them through the media the
way lebron james did to that cop
in minnesota then
this is what you end up with right you
end up
with these sorry that cop in ohio this
is what you end up with
you end up with cops backing off and you
work with citizens who act like
jackasses to the cops okay so corey bush
is a perfect example of she's a black
lives matter activist who ends up in
congress
she's an adjunct member of the squad
she's a representative from missouri and
she tweeted out our communities wouldn't
have needed to spark a national movement
to save black lives
if america weren't racist af
yes america is racist af the police are
terrible the police
are awful and you get al sharpton saying
the same thing to tim scott and america
was built on racism
now it's amazing to me if america was
built on racism why in the world is al
sharpton
still on tv this man is the greatest
race grifter of the last 50 years
involved in the incitement of not one
but two riots a complete liar
i mean a man who completely made up from
whole cloth the story of tawana bradley
and then slandered a a d.a in order to
get himself off the hook
al sharpton is a bag of human garbage
he's a terrible human being
and here's al sharpton lecturing about
how america is racist af while standing
there in presumably a thousand dollar
suit
here he is everybody in america is not
racist
but are you talking about whether the
practice of america's races
are the people because the practice of
america was built on racism
it was against the law for us to rewrite
it was against the law us to marry
it was against the law for us to name
our children's after us
we were brought here to serve and never
get paid
that's how the country was built okay my
favorite part of this is that none of
those things are true today and none of
those things have been true for decades
right and if you want to talk about
marriages and breaking up marriages and
he says we were never allowed to marry
the marriage rate among black americans
in 1900 was actually higher than the
marriage rate among white americans in
1900. the marriage rate today among
african americans
stands at approximately or children born
out of wedlock the marriage
children born out of wedlock rate today
is in excess of 70
okay when welfare came around it's about
20 percent
is that an after effect of racism and
slavery you have to explain why if that
is the case
okay but again all of this has
predictable effects and the predictable
effects of this
are that people treat cops badly and
then people suggest that america's a
terrible place and you are somehow
virtuous if you attack america
and then the result is that people just
don't do their jobs
the cops are not proactive it leads to
actual behavior
it leads to people abusing cops for
example there's a video that was going
viral i'm going to show you in just a
moment
a california woman and how she
interacted with the cops this is why
when people say
well you know the cops are all bad and
like you never see these videos
of the cops having to deal with
obnoxious people which pretty much every
day
there are literally tens and tens and
tens of millions of police encounters
with human beings
in the united states every year you
don't see nearly any of them
the only ones you see are the ones the
media decide to make an issue of but how
people act toward the cops some
does make a difference and when you
raise the temperature and when you say
the cops are bad and people start
acting terribly with the cops the
results sometimes go bad
we'll talk about that in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact that
you don't
want to go to an auto parts store why
would you want to go to an auto parts
store just stand in line for a long time
finally you get to the front they ask
you a bunch of questions
you don't know the answers to finally
you get the answers and then they're
like oh yeah we don't have that part
we're ordering it online
and you said yourself well why didn't i
just stay home and order it online yes
why didn't you go over to rockauto.com
rockauto.com will always offer the
lowest price possible rather than
changing prices based
on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much for the same parts
like say you know off the top my head
you need like a delphi fg 1456 fuel pump
assembly for a 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey
you just off the top of my head and it
cost like 354 bucks at a big chain store
that's the kind of thing you get at rock
auto for 217 bucks
right so you're looking at big savings
right now rockauto.com it's a family
business serving auto parts customers
online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
okay so this leads to certain
predictable effects when you
castigate the cops as racist when you
suggest that the cops are big danger to
americans
there's a video that i think is kind of
important because we very rarely talk
about the behavior of people when they
interact with police officers
you know we we hear very often that if
you're black in america you have to
teach your kids keep your hands at 10
and 2 on the wheel
treat the officer with respect first of
all you should teach your kids to do
that regardless of your color
because the cop is armed and you
presumably are not the cop is an officer
of law and you presumably are not
and you should be treating police
officers with respect that is a simple
thing to do
but put that aside for a second when you
incentivize people to treat cops badly
that is not a good idea and it does lead
to worse behaviors so for example here
is a california woman
who was pulled over for she had her cell
phone up on it which is a violation in
california you're not allowed to have
your cell phones your ear in california
i know because i used to live there she
was pulled over and uh this exchange
just says pretty much everything about
how
it is is seen fit to treat police
officers in america right now
why are you harassing you are correct i
pulled you over because you're a
murderer
yes i started to record because you
can't be it you can't be on your cell
phone while you're driving i was
recording you can you call your
supervisor please
i already did he's on his way because
you're a murderer okay do you have a
pictured
okay well i'm sorry you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer
okay thank you and i'm perfectly legal
and i'm a teacher so there
congratulations
you're a murderer okay now quick thing
here
one typically a thing that you cannot
say to murderers and get away with being
alive is is you're a murderer right
things that people never said to charles
manson
right i'm sorry that's such an absurdist
i'm a teacher it's a flag okay but
that sort of behavior is now being
incentivized like this lady thought for
sure
she was gonna go viral right that's why
she's taping it she thinks she's gonna
put that up on tiktok and she's gonna go
viral
look at how i spoke back to this
murdering pig officer okay that sort of
attitude
is not going to either get you anywhere
in life or going to incentivize the kind
of behaviors
that lead to a lowering of crime i think
police officers want to be treated this
way
you think police officers want to get
into situations and this is a pretty
mild situation the lady's not actually
physically resisting arrest for example
but to believe that that doesn't happen
is to ignore the evidence on the ground
okay and and
this has now infused so much of our
conversation
right the anti-police anti-american
rhetoric has infused so much
of our conversation that we're supposed
to ignore relevant stories
in favor of irrelevant stories we're
supposed to pay attention
to this lady's feeling about this cop
we're supposed to pay attention to
police officers doing the right thing
and shooting people who are threatening
other people but we're not supposed to
pay attention
to actual active active apparent malice
okay so this brings us to what in any in
any normal situation would lead the news
right this story would lead the news
here is the story
and it has not appeared so far somewhere
on any network news show i believe it
has not been covered at cnn
it's an unbelievable story so the most
glorified criminal justice trial since
rodney king
was the derek chauvin trial was the
number one trial covered in america the
derek chovin situation
spawned riots and protests the protest
involved somewhere between 15 and 26
million americans
according to studies and then
a couple weeks ago derek chovan was
convicted on all accounts and i said at
the time
i think you could get to manslaughter
maybe i think i find it very difficult
to believe that a jury could get to
second and third degree murder
after 10 hours of consideration with no
questions asked of the judge
i just thought it is very hard for me to
believe that you get there without any
preconceived notions after three weeks
of testimony you come in with a
conviction on all accounts second third
degree murder
and manslaughter on the basis of the
evidence that was provided
without asking any questions right in 10
hours i said i found that very difficult
to believe
and people were very upset with that how
could you say that this is how the
criminal justice system works which i
pointed out well if it had come out the
other way in 10 hours you would have
said that it was biased that way so
obviously you just don't like the
outcome what i'm saying is if they'd
considered this for a week
and then they'd come back with that
verdict i still would have thought they
got it wrong but at least i would have
thought they considered the evidence
you come back in 10 hours after a three
week trial on something like that
and it doesn't seem to me that the jury
did a great job considering the evidence
just on the basis of the these sort of
outside
on the basis of the the outside data
well now we know
now we know that at least one of these
jurors
was apparently an activist according to
daley wire
one of the jurors who served on the
murder trial of former minneapolis
police officer derrick chauvin
reportedly sported a black lives matter
t-shirt with a reference to the death of
george floyd
seemingly challenging what the juror
told the chauvin defense team during
jury selection
according to a report from the
post-millennial now public juror brandon
mitchell 31 is seen in a facebook post
published in august 2020 right well
before the trial august 2020
wearing a hat that says black lives
matter and a t-shirt that says blm
with the words get your knee off our
necks a reference to the death of floyd
the photo was posted by a travis
mitchell with the caption the next
generation being socially active
representing in dc my son marcel my
nephew brandon rene mitchell
and brother maurice john cena johnson
here's the photo in question was tweeted
out by jack bosobiac
also this person apparently runs a
podcast
mitchell told the judge on march 15th
when he was asked if he was aware of the
shoving case
and george floyd he said quote he'd
heard some basic info about trial dates
etc from the news
but not the sort of information that
would keep him from serving as an
impartial juror
apparently he also ran a podcast
covering george floyd and other racial
justice issues he then went on to give
an interview to the wall street journal
in which he describes how he decided to
go public to help push for change
and told of his many negative
experiences dealing with law enforcement
when he was younger
if mitchell was truly unfamiliar with
the george floyd case before joining the
jury
he certainly made up for lost time in a
hurry says hot air but that seems
patently preposterous
so where exactly does that leave us now
well it leaves you with a pretty strong
case for a mistrial
i mean this if this guy is the juror
which apparently he is
how is that not leading the news i mean
i i honestly don't understand how does
that not lead the news let's say that
derrick shoven had been
acquitted and it turns out one of the
jurors had been wearing a blue lives
matter t-shirt with a shirt that said
derek shoven is innocent
do you think that that might be the
cause of some consternation
but there have you seen the story
covered anywhere anywhere
because again the narrative must be
pursued at the cost of the fact at the
cost of individual justice
if need if need be pretty astonishing
stuff we'll get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact a lot of us are going to
be on the move again this summer
my advice take your recons with you
right as we get back to regular life and
as you're enjoying life getting outside
really enjoying yourself
make sure you have a great pair of
wireless earbuds a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference no matter what you're
listening to
yet crisp powerful beats at half the
price of other premium audio brands
raycons look great they feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors with
customizable gel tips included for a
comfortable in-ear fit
raycons are built to go wherever you go
with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and
compact charging case listen up raycon
right now is offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
here's what you've got to do to go get
it go to buyrecon.com
there you will get 15 off your entire
recon order it's such a good deal you'll
want to grab a pair and a spare
that is 15 off at buy raycon.com again
that's by raycon dot com slash band b
y r ay c o n dot com slash been one of
my favorite things about my raycons they
fit my ear perfectly because you can
actually
customize them to fit your ear they come
in a variety of colors they're really
cool
they sound great and they last a while
check out buyracon.com
and get 15 off your product from
recon.com
by raycon.com ben okay so
all of this has a predictable impact the
predictable impact is that
we are only supposed to follow the
narratives that the media would like us
to follow the narratives are that the
cops are bad
and if you yell at the cops this makes
you good the narrative is that
cops don't deserve impartial jurors
after all we know systemic police racism
means that derek chovan is a racist even
though not an iota of evidence was
provided for the idea
that derek shelvin was a racist america
is racist which means that tim scott is
bad you can be as racist to tim scott
as you want to be and not only that the
left has a prerogative in cramming all
this down on your children
because critical race theory is being
rammed into the public schools
this is something that's being pushed by
the biden administration
and by the media particularly we talked
about this at length yesterday
the media of course treated as an act of
aggression when conservatives notice
what the left is doing so left has
something truly astonishing and terrible
and the right goes that's terrible and
the left goes how dare you notice you're
pouncing now
here's the piece from the washington
post's education section
as schools expand racial equity work
conservatives see a new threat
in critical race theory how dare they
laura meckler and hannah natetensen
right i mean it's just propaganda talk
right here
the nation's reckoning over race again
always that word reckoning over race
it's always a reckoning
uh how about an ongoing debate over how
best to teach our children wouldn't that
be
a more objective way of determining a
reckoning or reckoning of course
suggests that america is nationally
guilty and now has to pay a price and
that price will come in the form of how
we indoctrinate your kids
the nation's reckoning over race has
reached thousands of u.s schools and so
too has a conservative backlash
backlash schools across the country says
the washington post are working to
address
systemic racism and inject an
anti-racist mindset into campus life oh
is that what they're doing
so you're taking for granted that
systemic racism is the thing and you're
going to use the language of the left
they would never use this sort of
language with regard to any right-wing
movement
imagine if it said schools across the
country are working to address the
killing of the unborn
and to inject a pro-life mindset into
campus life would you ever see
that line in the washington post of
course not but where advocates see
racial progress opponents see an effort
to shame white teachers and sometimes
students for being part of an oppressive
system
i mean honest to god i don't like did
imbrem kendi write this article
in particular conservatives have seized
on the idea that schools are promoting
critical race theory
a decades-old academic framework that
examines how policies and the law
perpetuates systemic racism it holds in
part that racism is woven into the
fabric of the nation's history and life
a product of the system and not just
individual bad actors
well it doesn't hold that in part it
holds that in full i mean the critical
race theory says that all of our
institutions are corrupt it's the same
crap that al sharpton is spewing right
there
or that cory bush is spewing right there
critics say this approach injects race
into what should be in their view a
colorblind system
proponents counter us schools have never
been colorblind and insist they aren't
pushing critical race theory anyway
the equity work is critical they say to
address systemic barriers holding back
students of color
and to create schools that are truly
inclusive notice all the mush words here
systemic barriers okay define them like
testing because they're trying to get
rid of testing in new york city because
testing
is too beneficial to asian american
students who are doing incredibly well
on the tests
to create schools that are truly
inclusive what do you mean truly
inclusive are any of these schools
borrowing black students
and if they are merit-based schools is
that non-inclusive
the issues are widespread data
consistently show that students of color
are more likely to be disciplined
than their white peers and receive
harsher punishments for the same
infractions
actually that's not what the date of the
show what the data tend to show is that
students of color are more likely to be
disciplined but it's not clear they
receive harsher punishments for these
same infractions it depends on the
record of the student prior
previously and the school they go to
black and hispanic students are less
likely to be placed in advanced or
enriched classes starting in elementary
school okay usually that is based on
the teachers making a determination and
or testing
many experts say school curricula have
failed to adequately reflect the
perspectives of indigenous and
marginalized communities so
yes we're going to indoctrinate your
kids in a bunch of diversity courses
and students and parents themselves
often report that school culture does
not feel welcoming oh well if it doesn't
feel welcoming
okay so there's been massive blow back
against this and the left doesn't like
it
that blowback has come in the form of
conservatives saying you don't get to
indoctrinate our kids in all of your
racial and racist crap which prompted
nicole hannon jones the
pseudo-journalist at the new york times
a purveyor of pre-varication and garbage
to say
how dare they try and stop people from
teaching the 1619 project to small
children this is a free speech issue no
it's an educational issue
it is not a free speech issue and by the
way there's a great irony to nicole
hannah jones
one of the people who loves cancellation
more than nearly anybody else in
american life she said the people in the
media should have a reckoning over
january 6. like people should get fired
if they backed trump here she is saying
oh people are being mean to me world's
tiniest violin for this liar
this is fundamentally a free speech
issue if you look at the rhetoric of
senator mcconnell and of state
legislators all across the country that
are
trying to get bills passed to prohibit
the teaching of the 1619 project
it's not about the facts of history it's
about trying to prohibit the teaching of
ideas that they don't like so
we you know i've been a little appalled
by the silence
of free speech advocates as their these
attempts to ban ideas from being taught
this is not a free speech issue this is
a k-12 education issue which is
controlled by local school boards
the hell is she talking about nobody's
saying that nicole hannah jones should
lose her job
i mean she sucks at her job but i don't
think she should frankly i think they
should make her just official eic of the
new york times so they can completely
blow out their credibility that seems
like a positive move to me
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that right now you're probably not
thinking too much about
things you can do to better your sleep
quality right if you are then you've
probably already gone maybe you got a
better pillow or maybe got a better
mattress but one thing you didn't think
about is the sheets okay the sheets you
sleep on
they have to be quality in fact the
sheets i sleep on bowling brand sheets
let me just tell you i got rid of all
the other sheets in my house that are
that good
if you dream of comfortable sheets at a
price that won't keep you up at night
look no further than bowl and branch
bowling branch makes the softest organic
sheets on the market
they get better with every wash and
comfort is not their only standard they
use 100 sustainable raw products
as the first fair trade certified
manufacturer of linen you can feel as
good about the bowl and brand sheets as
they feel against your skin
the signature hem sheets from bowling
branch are our best seller for a reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
and a classic sateen weave for sheets
that get softer over time
not too hot knots you call the perfect
year-round sheets for most sleepers
bowl and branch focuses on quality over
quantity no inflated thread count here
because more isn't always better
you always see that you drive past like
a gas station like one million thread
counter like oh must be great got a lot
of threads
you don't even know what that means okay
the reality is you need the sheets from
poland branch they are
indeed fantastic experience the best
sheets you've ever felt at bowl and
branch dot com get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
use promo code shapiro at checkout
that's bowl and branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com
promo code shapiro to get 15 off your
first set of sheets these are amazing
sheets you're going
to love them okay so again all of this
is part and parcel
of the left's attempt to take over
institutions and they want to take over
the institutions of policing and destroy
policing they want to take over the
institutions of education and destroy
education
and then they want to force you into the
corner with regard to covid with a bunch
of just sheer nonsense there will be
blowback to this by the way you can see
the blowback happening the blowback to
critical race theory in the public
schools
is going to be severe and it should be
severe there are people like chris ruffo
doing an excellent job
of exposing the predations of critical
race theory in the classroom
there will be blowback nbc news can say
that the country is heavily divided on
this stuff it is not
in texas that school board won 70 30
against crt because crt is a bunch of
propagandistic bs
okay and there's going to be blowback
against covet as well because the
standards that are being pushed by the
left with regard
to covet masking social distance social
distancing
they do not make any sense at all let me
give you an example of how little sense
any of the stuff being pushed by the
left makes uncovered so
you'll recall because i've played it a
couple of times on the show that the
president of the united states
joe biden that joe biden has said that
it is a
patriotic duty man to wear your mask
yeah i'm i'm vaccinated
and imagine and even though i vaccinated
him double daxed
even though that's how if i sat next to
you
jim bob billy joe pony soldier if i sat
next to you
and you were vacs i'd wear a mask it's
patriotic man
come on man i don't even wear a mask
outside
for no reason at all cause masks
yeah dude come on okay so
you remember he said all that and it was
crazy and wild and made no sense and
conflicted with his own cdc standards
well now he went to georgia and he
visited with jimmy carter
first of all let me just note this
picture which was put out by the carter
center
never use this kind of fish-eye lens
whatever you whatever lens you were
using in this picture of carter center
people
don't do it ever again this is one of
the creepiest pictures i have ever seen
this looks like forced perspective from
lord of the rings where elijah wood is
sitting next to ian mckellen they're
actually the same size
but elijah wood is three feet tall and
ian mckellen is seven feet tall
this picture is of joe biden for those
who can't see first of all you should go
look at the picture because it's
hysterically funny
it's joe biden kneeling next to a chair
where jimmy carter says jimmy carter is
96 years old so you can't blame him for
sitting
and lady bird carter is sitting next to
joe biden joe biden is kneeling down on
the floor
and jill and joe
look like they could play center in the
nba both of them
now jill biden is like not all that big
jill biden is something like five foot
five and joe biden is six foot
he looks like he is andre the giant in
this photo
and lady bird and jimmy look like they
are straight from the lollipop guild
i don't know what what happened here
with the lens
but um it is super duper weird
it looks like we elected giant monsters
to be president
and first lady of the united states best
tweet on this that i saw was
watch watch jimmy carter recite the
malay speech while jill biden drinks a
glass of water
it looks like charlie mccarthy here with
jill biden it's so weird man
this is our leadership class oh this is
so weird
okay so it's and then they've got like
an open armoire in the back or something
like a door behind
joe that looks like it's going to lead
to narnia and i
i don't even know what what is this it's
like this weird
tiny china dolls next to next like i
know jimmy carter and lady bird aren't
like two feet tall what did you do
carter center why would you do this
that's not actually the point of me
bringing this up i mean sure it's
hilarious and strange
and um also hilarious but the actual
point here is if you
you may have noticed that neither jill
nor joe are masked here next to two
people
who are in their late 90s i mean
these are jimmy carter had health
problems i assume both of them are
vaccinated at this point
and jill and joe are right next to him
but i was informed that even if both of
you are vaccinated you should
mess up now the part of this is that's
hilarious is that
as soon as they leave the house then
there's a picture of joe and jill
putting on masks
so i don't know either joe's a liar
about his own masking standards or
joe and jill were attempting some sort
of assassination
against these tiny treasured members of
american society
i i don't know what
none of the standards make any sense and
the media of course are promulgating the
confusion they love the confusion
they have a piece in the health section
of the washington post titled
more than a year into the pandemic we're
still figuring out what risks we're
willing to take oh are we
are we because i will tell you what risk
i am willing to take
i've been vaccinated i've been double
vaxxed with the
world-class platinum-grade pfizer
vaccine
and let me tell you my risk tolerance i
am now immortal
okay like i'm i'm willing to go
i'm joking god okay but i i'm not
worried about covet at all because you
shouldn't be worried about covered with
your double backs end of story
you should be done you should take off
your mask you should go back to regular
life because
the chances of you dying of cove after
you've been vaxed in the united states
87 million people have been fully
vaccinated in the united states 88
people 88 out of 87
million people have died of covet after
being double-backed in the united states
88 your chances are one million and
according to the washington post not
according to me according to the
washington post
there is no data to suggest that the
that the
vaccinated are either a chief vector of
transmission or a major vector of
transmission or indeed even a vector of
transmission
there is no data for this at this point
and yet we are still hearing the talking
up of covered panic from places like the
washington post
quote when the centers for disease
control and prevention last week issued
guidelines for what vaccinated people
can do
the agency employed the word risk 43
times the word often carried a modifier
like increased risk residual risk low
risk potential risk minimal risk higher
risk
the cdc did not define low minimal or
higher instead using broad brush strokes
to paint a picture of post-vaccination
life yes of course they didn't because
that would imply that they have to
present data they don't want to present
data at the cdc they want to present
whatever propaganda joe biden wants to
present today
because in this dystopian future where
joe biden controls your life he doesn't
bother to present any data
the reality is the cdc is supposed to
prevent you with science and then you're
supposed to make decisions but
our great ultra criterion scientists
have decided they are going to
tell you exactly what you can and cannot
do for example
it says in the cdc standards indoor
visits or small gatherings likely
represent minimal risks to fully
vaccinated people
on wednesday cdc director rachelle
wolenski who ought to be fired forthwith
said she could not give a definitive
answer to what a small gathering is
because there are too many variables um
why
i have a question why is that um
why is that why are there too many
variables the answer is
there are not too many variables you
should be able to get together with a
million vaccinated people
in fact if you're vaccinated you should
really be able to get together with a
million non-vaccinated people because
you're not going to die of covid
by the odds okay if we define a small
and medium-sized gathering says wolenski
we also have to define the size of the
space that we're in the ventilation that
is occurring the space between
no you don't once you're vaccinated
you're vaccinated and once you're with
an
another vaccinated person you ain't
passing this to each other by statistics
by data the hell are you talking about
listen i trust the science which is why
i don't trust rachelle willenski who it
turns out was taking full-on cues
from the american federation of teachers
and randy weingarten in writing
education standards
there will just as there's going to be
blowback on the policing front because
the left is pushed way too far
because they don't like the cops and
they've made it very clear they think
the cops are quote unquote systemically
racist
joe biden gets up in the state of the
union he says things like yeah the cops
are
the cops are wonderful people most of
them and not racist and also
systemically racist like okay so
you're just a damned liar and they do
the same thing with kovid
we're getting back to regular life also
wear a mask when you go to the toilet by
herself
so thank god there are places like
florida where i live
where the governance is excellent
governor ron desantis in florida he for
example came out yesterday and he
slammed the biden approach
to vaccination because that approach is
garbage
here was ron desantis this is clip six
when you have people particularly in
washington saying
yeah get vaccinated but then make sure
you continue to social distance and wear
mass all the time well
the message that that sends to people is
that the vaccines don't work
because if the vaccines worked that
would be your ticket
to make basically live normally and make
decisions for yourself that would
that would be the message that actually
would work with people so i think that
they've sent a message
to say you know what get vaccinated but
it really ain't going to do anything for
you well why would someone want to put
something in their arm if they don't
think it's effective
and the fact of the matter is that is an
anti-science
posture to say that we need all these
restrictions even with mass vaccination
because the numbers of the vaccines are
better than the clinical trials were in
terms of the effectiveness
correct this is a desantis has been
ripped up and down by your lying
lying media for full on a year here
because they're afraid of him running in
2024.
desantis is a stud he actually studies
the science he's been looking at the
he cites the science he knows the signs
that he a hell of a lot better than joe
biden
who doesn't know his ass from a hole in
the ground and joe biden is barely
sentient at this point and we're
supposed to take his view of the science
under consideration absolute sheer
nonsense this is why people are moving
to florida gang
and ron desantis recently said the best
real estate agent for florida is new
york
correct alrighty before we go any
further
let me remind you the daily wire has
been just growing like crazy
we didn't just move the entire company
like to nashville and then i moved to
florida and we struck up a movie deal
with gina carano we released our first
feature film
we launched a new talk show hosted by
candice owens we watched my new show
debunked
all within the last six months we have
all sorts of amazing
stuff coming down the pike for you and
we just want to express our gratitude to
you
our audience for making this possible
because we couldn't grow this way
without you we want to include you in
our future plans
every day on the show you hear me
talking about a lot of our sponsors
but first birch gold i love our sponsors
we want to get to know you better so we
can actually tailor our sponsors so that
it's stuff that you want to hear about
please go to dailywire.com fill out my
audience survey tell us a little bit
more about yourself and to sweeten that
whole experience
those of you who complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1 000
gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show
so if you want to increase your chances
of winning a thousand bucks go listen to
michael knowles andrew claven or matt
walsh to get access to their surveys as
well
again my survey link is dailywire.com
shapiro we'd love to hear from you also
if you have not checked out candace's
show yet you've been missing out
especially considering tonight's live
stream premiere is free
features a guest that needs no
introduction donald trump
they discuss everything from big tech
censorship to what trump's future halls
believe me
it gets spicy candace is free for the
duration of the livestream it'll only be
available to members after it ends catch
it live tonight 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central only on dailywire.com if you
haven't subscribed yet this is your last
week to get 25
off with code canvas before the
promotion ends this thursday may 6th
make sure you grab the audio podcast on
apple spotify or whatever your platform
of choice
may be because candace says things the
media just
won't just head over to apple podcast
for spotify subscribe to canvas today be
sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
hey joe biden's approach to this whole
masking situation is ridiculous and
counterproductive
here's a new york times poll okay
there's a new york times poll today
asking
how likely would you be to get the
vaccine when it was available to you if
it meant you
no longer had to wear a mask okay
republicans 53
say they would be likely to get the
vaccine if it meant they no longer had
to wear a mask
35 said they'd be interested in the
vaccine if they still had to wear a mask
that is an 18 point increase in support
if you could take off your mask
and it's true for every subgroup in
american life white people are 15
more likely to get the vaccine if they
can take off their mass black people are
more likely overall 13 percent of
americans more likely to get the vaccine
if they were told they could take off
their mass so joe biden is being not
only an idiot
he is being an a scientific and
anti-scientific
it's just it's ridiculous and and yet we
are supposed to listen
to these utopian leftists on their
prescriptions so they're wrong on the
cops they are wrong on covet dr marti
bakari who's been a frequent guest on
the program
he says correctly the cdc has been late
or wrong since the pandemic began
the cdc has been consistently late or
wrong
and sometimes both for most of the major
issues that we faced during the pandemic
on
warning us about the pandemic on masks
on testing
on schools on being outdoors
consistently
and right now we've got a situation
where it's the wild west in terms of
businesses trying to figure out when to
bring employees back
jp morgan and salesforce have radically
different plans
every company is left to sort of
figuring this out on their own
and what you've got is large companies
hiring expensive consultants and small
businesses
which are most businesses in this
country are they can't afford these
expensive consultants and they're just
trying to
figure it out on their own reinventing
the wheel okay they are reinventing the
wheel this whole thing is
super stupid and this is why people are
leaving the blue states they're leaving
because blue states are governed like
horse crap they are governed
terribly you're going to see rising
crime in blue areas in blue states
you're going to see a continual cram
down of
top down control in these areas and
people are not going to take it so i
have a question
if you look at the governance in these
areas and you think to yourself
why would i trust biden on the economy
you are thinking
correctly joe biden is about to inflate
the currency okay we're watching it
happen in real
you know when all the experts tell you
the experts the same experts who said
don't mask at the very beginning
and then they said you have to shut down
the schools and then they said you have
to keep asking even if you're vaccinated
when that same cadre the new ruling
class i talk about
this group of people and how they are
formed in my brand new book that is
coming out in july
the authoritarian moment and go check
that out for pre-order right now
when this class of people tells you
anything your first move should be doubt
it doesn't mean they're wrong but it
should be down particularly when it's
overwhelming
when there's a 100 consensus you don't
have to worry about inflation you think
yourself wait a second we're going to
try and blow 10 trillion dollars into
the american economy
after blowing seven trillion dollars
into the american economy last year
minimum
above and beyond the budget and you are
and your your idea is that that we
somehow are not going to get inflation
you can guarantee that
and yet this is what is being promoted
endless spending
endless spending right joe biden by
again the man cannot speak
sentient paragraphs at this point so
yesterday he just told the overt lie
that if you make under 400 thousand
dollars you won't pay a single dollar in
taxes
presumably he meant you won't pay a
single additional dollar in taxes which
again is a lie
corporate taxes hit people who make
under 400 000 a year also the white
house says that if you're a couple
making four hundred thousand dollars a
year
that means that you will be subject to
the 400 000 penalty
so if you make 250 and your wife makes
150 or the reverse
you will be paying the same tax rate as
the guy who makes four hundred and fifty
four hundred thousand dollars a year
that's a pretty major change from his
original promise sounds like two
individuals who aren't making four
hundred thousand dollars
paying higher taxes in any case here was
joe biden just saying ridiculous things
about taxes
the reason i'm bothering to do this is i
keep hearing on the press biden's going
to raise your taxes
anybody making less than 400
000 a year will not pay a single penny
in taxes
oh weird also he says that the american
families plan his new two trillion
dollar boondoggle directed at spending
more money than god has ever seen
uh that it won't add a penny to our
deficit and if you believe this
then joe biden has a bridge in brooklyn
that is available for sale
here's what the american family plan
doesn't do it doesn't add a single penny
to our deficit
it's paid for by making sure corporate
america and the wealthiest one percent
just pay their fair share i come from
the corporate capital of the world
more corporations are incorporating the
state of delaware
than all the rest of the nation combined
and i'm not anti-corporate but it's
about time they start
paying their fair share this is such a
nonsensical line whenever people like
biden say things like
they need to pay their fair share let me
explain dude
the top 10 of income earners in the
united states pay
all net taxes in the united states all
like all of them 100 of net taxes in the
united states are paid by the top 10
percent of income earners and when you
tax corporations what do you think
happens you make them less competitive
on the world stage they bleed down the
tax increases to consumers so prices
rise
and they take more money out of the
pockets of their own employees
so that joe biden can spend it on
whatever idiotic
depends products he feels like spending
it on that day it's absurd
okay and then jill the good news is that
we have dr jill to tell us how we should
spend our money too
and honestly one of the most annoying
things in public life is when we pretend
that the spouses of people we elect are
actually elected officials i don't
understand why we do this
it makes no sense like yes my wife is a
doctor also don't come to me for medical
advice
go to my wife for medical advice i
didn't go to medical school she went to
medical school
i do politics don't go to my wife for
her political prognostications she
doesn't know things about that
why in the world do we treat the first
lady this is true by in bipartisan
fashion i don't we didn't elect
joe biden we didn't elect hillary
clinton to be the co-president
of the united states as bill clinton
once suggested we
we did not elect laura bush we did not
elect michelle obama
it seems to really only apply with
democrats where they actually try and
make
the first lady into a political figure
of some sort of weight and impact
but it is it is a point of high
irritation to me that we pretend that
the first lady should have any impact on
american public life
she's along for the ride and it would be
pres douglas emhoff
is a dude i care zero bleeps about what
doug adamhoff has to say he's not an
elected official
but here's joe biden jill biden who
wrote an amazing dissertation
an incredible dissertation on junior
college
when she was at the university of
delaware she worked hard for that
doctorate in for dds in education
at a university with a building named
after her husband
i mean that no no inside baseball there
at all it was probably the best
dissertation anybody ever wrote except
for how it wasn't because it's publicly
available anyway
here's dr joel the greatest doctor in
all the land explaining that in her
opinion
we should just bust out the wallet and
start spending for free
community college for everybody because
that's really what we need what we need
is credential inflation we need to make
sure that people who only graduate high
school are disadvantaged
as compared to people who go to
community college and study a couple of
years in english lit
makes perfect sense here's joe biden
saying silly things
community college graduates promot
provide
more security for their families they
invest in their local schools and
businesses
and they bring needed skills to our
workforce
helping us to meet the challenges of the
21st century
that's why we need two years of
free community college yeah
we need two free years of community two
and free chicken and everybody needs two
belly buttons
and a horse that's what we need and all
the money
and blowing money into the economy it
won't have any impact at all you know
how we know won't have any impact
because the smartest people have told us
it won't have any impact at all i mean
in fact they say inflation is not going
to hurt us in any way
also new york times today widespread
commodity shortages raise inflation
fears
oh who could have predicted that blowing
needless money into an economy that's
already in a state of recovery
would inflate the currency and inflate
prices who could have predicted such a
thing except for any person who
understands how inflation works
according to the new york times in a
normal year ron whelan vice president of
roger b kennedy construction
receives one or two dear valued customer
letters from suppliers
notifying him of price increases for
certain materials this year a stack of
30 such warnings
sits on his desk in orlando florida
alerting him that things as diverse as
lumber drywall aluminum and steel
are going to cost 10 to 20 more the
notices are the result of commodity
shortages that are rippling across the
united states economy
as growing demand for housing cars
electronics and other goods runs up
against the supply chain congestion and
high tariffs
left behind by former president donald j
trump so i love that the first two
paragraphs they're like
look at that the prices are just
skyrocketing for this sort of stuff
trump it's like he hasn't been president
for a while here guys
like he hasn't been here since january
and i'm noticing
that it says this year a stack of 30
such this year is 2021.
donald trump was president of the united
states for a grand total of 20 days in
2021.
now i'm no fan of tariffs but the chief
driver right now of inflation
ain't the tariffs the chief driver right
because it would have been the driver of
inflation a year ago or two years ago
the the chief driver of inflation right
now is the fact that you are blowing
into the economy money you do not need
to spend and has not been created yet
the shortages and the price increases
they are eliciting are being watched
closely by the biden administration
which is under increasing pressure from
industry groups and businesses to take
steps to ease them
automakers want the white house to help
them get the semiconductors they need to
make cars
while the housing industry is asking for
tariff relief pressure to intervene
could intensify
as the administration pushes for a
multi-trillion dollar infrastructure
investment package that includes money
for building roads
bridges and electric vehicle charging
stations all of which could become
increasingly expensive if prices keep
rising
why they haven't waited for things to
settle down and get back to normal we
keep waiting for things to settle back
settle down and get back to normal but
they haven't said mr whalen he's
considered using other material
such as metal stud systems rather than
wood framing for some construction
projects because the price of lumber has
almost tripled
in the last year economists and
policymakers are carefully tracking the
shortages as they hunt for signs of
inflation
and companies are increasingly worried
that the price spikes may not be
temporary
oh you think oh for now the fed is not
overly concerned about the price
increases
viewing them as temporary and not the
type of inflation that could spiral out
of control
well i mean if the fed is good for one
thing it's making amazing predictions
about the economy
they did an amazing job in the lead up
to the great reset
and they did an unbelievable job and
lead up to the dot com um and they did
an incredible job
in the lead-up to the yeah the the
experts
trust them trust them on kovit where
they've been wrong throughout
trust them when it comes to race where
they're not just wrong but evil
trust them when it comes to blowing
money into the economy we don't have
because what could be the downside what
could be the downside
and the answer of course is that the
downside is precisely the reverse of
what they are promising
less prosperity less earnings less
lifestyle less equality less equity
by the way less fairness we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of the ben shapiro show
go check out the mount wall show he'll
be talking more about the video of the
california woman and latino cop watch at
1 30 pm eastern over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
morin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show